موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
قال رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه
مارك ميلي ان الجيش الروسي يعاني بشده في
اوكرانيا ان هناك احتمال للحل السياسي فقط
روسيا من كامل اراضي اوكرانيا في القريب
العاجل احتمال مستوى
الدفاع الامريكي
المتحده لا تملي على الاوكرانيين ما ينبغي
عليهم فعله واكد ان وضع شبه جزيره القرم
امر يعود للقياده الاوكرانيه
قال الرئيس
ميرازيليسكي ان روسيا لم تقدم اي عرض لعقد
مباحثات مع كيفه وجدد جريسكي تمسكه بان
الصاروخ الذي سقط في الاراضي البولنديه
يوما الاربعاء لم يكن اوكرانيه
من ناحيته قبل رئيس البولنديه ليست هناك
اي مؤشرات على ان الصاروخ الذي سقط داخل
حدود بلاده اطلق به شكل المقصود واصفا
الامر بانه حادث مؤسف واضاف ان الصاروخ
الذي سقط في بولندا اطلقته الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكانيه على الارشح
بينما قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان
الحادثه لا توفى في روسيا من مسؤوليتها
الاساسيه في الحرب حدث موسكو وارسو على
عدم تورط فيما سمتها بالاستفزازات القذره
التي يرتكبها نظامك
تعرضت ناقله نفط لهجوم قبله سواحل عمان
وقد افادت وكاله وسوشيه بريس بان الهجوم
تم بطائره مسيره مفخخه في حين قالت
رجل اعمال اسرائيلي
بينما قال مسؤول عسكري للجزيره ان الطائر
المسيره من طراز شاهد دانا مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي الهجوم واضاف انه بمراجعه
المعلومات فان ايران ربما استخدمت مسيره
لشن الهجوم على الناقله اشار الى ان
الهجوم يهدد حريه الملاحه والتجاره
الدوليه
والتغيير
حكومه مدنيه كامله سيوقع مع المكون
العسكري في السلطه في غضون عشره
قوى الحريه والتغيير
مجلس الوزراء مدنيه بالكامل
قالت رويترز عن مصادر العسكريه سودانيه
قولها انها توصلت الى تفاهمات مع قوى
الحريه والتغيير وما زالت هناك بنود
عاليقه
ناحيته قال مفوض الامم المتحده سامي لحقوق
الانسان
للجزيره ان لديه تفاؤل حذرا بشان امكانيه
التوصل الى توافق سياسي بين القوى المدنيه
والسلطه العسكريه في السودان واوضح ان
الدوله المجتمع الدولي هو دعم اي اطار
سياسيه يتوافق بشانه السوداني
[موسيقى]